so in this video we get to see the final
form of Venom how Godly powerful he
becomes and then he gets a lightsaber
which is dope so what this does here is
this opens up with Meridius and we will
talk about how all this comes together
because either you guys don't know or
maybe some of you guys have forgotten we
will make sense of all of it but while
Meridius is here it actually focuses on
a guy by the name of Tyro and again
we'll explain this timeline but Tyro is
talking to Meridius and actually trying
to talk to him about something now of
course Meridius largely just ignores
Tyro just kind of blows him off and so
the result of this is that Tyro is
trying to understand his own destiny
what's his point in being here in the
garden what's the purpose and so what he
ends up doing here is he actually dives
into the heart of the garden itself
again we'll make all this make sense
bear with me here for a second but he
dies Into the Heart of the garden and
when he does he wakes up in the realm of
the eventuality the heart part of the
garden now this is where the explanation
comes into play because he asked the
question he says did Meridius do this
when he was me is this the path he took
it must be and yet I'm at the heart of
the garden this symbiot Hive and it's a
sea of death I'm seeing visions of the
Dead symbiot Minds All Around Me Astros
skeletons consumed husks but there's
something still alive here something
familiar the seventh Eddy it calls
itself the eventuality and somehow it
too is Eddie Brock but in a shape I've
never seen before now here's where the
explanation comes into play right so
what you have really with this whole run
on Venom and the way that it changed
things is as most of you guys even if
only from the movies are aware
Spider-Man at some point got the Venom
symbiot he got rid of it it went to
Eddie Brock Eddie Brock became a villain
for a while and fought Spider-Man done
the way this works out kind of building
on a lot of the stuff that came after is
what it establishes is it says Eddie
Brock becomes Venom and then eventually
null the symbiot God Appears Eddie Brock
fights null Eddie Brock defeats null
Eddie Brock replaces null and becomes
the new King in black and as the king in
Black he has complete control of every
symbiot Across the Universe the kicker
here is this happens in every Universe
across the Multiverse but when Eddie
Brock becomes the king in Black his path
can take two directions two tracks
that's why this eventuality says not on
this track you haven't right what
happens when Eddie becomes a king in
black is he can either fulfill his role
as the king in Black which is basically
being a kind of police force for the
universe using the Symbiotes to protect
the universe from any threats that
exists out there assuming the Symbiotes
are capable of handling that threat and
then when that Universe dies by whatever
Manner and whatever means right dies
from its heat Death Dies because Thanos
loses his mind with the Infinity
Gauntlet blinks the whole thing out of
existence whatever happens to take place
that Eddie Brock will travel to the UN
Beyond this hand that you see here is
the sum total of every version of Eddie
Brock who is the king in Black from
across the Multiverse that has merged
together into a singular form it's
astronomically powerful it exists on a
multiversal level there's only one of
these throughout the entirety of the
Multiverse so it's not that dissimilar
from the role of like the beyonders or
the Living Tribunal or something along
those lines we don't know how far that
stretch is but that's kind of what it is
now the other path that Eddie Brock can
take is actually the one that we see
unfolding here which is to say Eddie
Brock can die in his Universe while he's
the king in Black before the universe
dies and instead of traveling to the UN
Beyond he arrives in a place called The
Garden which is kind of a circular
pattern so the easiest way to understand
this is imagine that you died and then
you travel to kind of an after life not
the one you're supposed to go to but a
different one and when you get there you
end up realizing that over time you'll
experience the five stages of grief
right anger denial bargaining uh
depression and then acceptance I might
have gotten those out of order but
imagine that each one of those stages is
represented as a physical version of you
as you're in that stage so you show up
there you've been there for five minutes
in a year you'll go through anger that
version of you is there you'll go
through denial then you'll go through
depression then you'll go through
bargaining and then you'll go through
acceptance you can talk to all those
versions of yourself at the same time
that's what's going on with Eddie Brock
here the reason why that's so
significant is because Meridius is kind
of the final stage right acceptance if
you will but what Meridius had done is
actually something that we'll see over
the course of this in terms of how he
created the garden his involvement with
Kang and all that stuff but Meridius is
trying to to defy his fate he doesn't
want to join the UN Beyond he doesn't
want to go there instead he wants to
rule the entirety of the universe as a
king in Black separate from the UN
Beyond and so that's why this whole
story is happening the way that it is
hopefully it clears things up hopefully
I haven't lost too many of you guys and
in fact even Tyro himself right one of
these versions of Eddie Brock he makes
this comment and he says and in that
moment I feel a crowd around me a crowd
of other selves
possibilities all of the approaches I
could have taken to this moment of
Enlightenment and the road that leads
here because every road Leads Here the
eventuality tells me every path the king
in Black can take leads to this eternal
servitude manifesting eternity itself in
Eternal darkness and so Tyro fleas right
it's a desire to simply not serve in
darkness for the rest of his day he's
fearful of that because everything that
he values in life and everything he
misses will be gone for all of eternity
it terrifies him not that dissimilar
from like Voldemort and Harry Potter who
was simply scared of death because he
didn't know what happened next Tyro
knows what happens next and he hates the
idea of it right he says I don't want it
when I panic it's all too easy to UNM
more myself from the present and flee
desperately into the arms of time so one
of the things to know is that the garden
itself exists out outside of space and
time so to jump out of the heart of the
garden the way that Tyro did is
basically jumping off a diving board and
landing in a pool except the pool itself
is the entirety of the universe who
knows where you would end up and so as
he's talking to himself he says but now
that I'm in the time stream where can I
go how can I outrun my own fate when I
was Eddy I tried to change things even
after I was told that it could not be
done but who was it that told me and
that that's when he remembers he spoke
to King the Conqueror at a previous
point in time and so he seeks him out
because earlier in the Venom run Eddie
did try to do that when Eddie realized
that he was eventually going to become
Meridius right this just evil version of
himself he went to Kang and ask the
question how can I keep that from
happening and the response of Kang is
there's no way you can that is who
you're going to become it's like trying
to stop yourself from becoming 30 when
you're 15 the only way to prevent that
would just be you cease to exist and you
can't do that right and so what he does
right what Tyro does is in leaping into
the time stream he just tries to find
conquest and what he ends up doing is
coming across a world out there in the
universe that is exceedingly primitive
life hasn't necessarily formed here but
that lizards will grow from the rocks
and they'll eventually develop an
organized society and then they'll
challenge Kang King the Conqueror being
the Conqueror that he is goes back in
time before this race can evolve and
wipes them all out thereby eliminating
the entire possib ility of them
challenging him in the first place of
course that's probably a concept that
we're never going to see manifest in the
MCU which sucks but Tyro appears and
Tyro starts talking to Kang and so what
Kang says is I can help you achieve what
it is that you want to achieve he kind
of presents him with a holographic image
of the universe and says each one of
these dots is a Galaxy and I can give
you this I can present you with this
right he says behold the universe in a
hard light hologram each dot of light is
a Galaxy by the way go ahead and feel
the quality all this my friend if you
play my game on my board by my rules all
this can be yours and Tyro says okay and
so what king starts to do is show him
how to harness his abilities and that's
really the big difference between like
Tyro bedum any of the other versions of
Eddie that are here and Meridius
Meridius has total control over
everything that a symbiot can possibly
do Tyro kind of has your traditional
symbiot Powers your traditional Venom
Powers what he ends up learning is to
bring his face back he's given a
lightsaber which is amazing this is not
his final form by the way but he's given
a lightsaber by Kang which is pretty
dope right like he's learning combat
learning how to fight in fact they end
up harnessing abilities and just kind of
he joins King on travels while King does
like normal King stuff and he even gets
a little overwhelmed by the complexity
of King's just nature right traveling
back and forth Through Time and all the
craziness that goes along with it but
then he starts to think about his son
Dylan who back on Earth is just
operating as a kind of superhero and so
on and so forth and he says I haven't
thought about my son in a long time it
was better that way I'm nothing but a
danger to him now last time I tried to
interfere in his life he almost died and
he says but with what King's taught me I
can send my mind through time I can
catch a glimpse of him and Venom just a
a peak just to check that he's safe and
so he sends his mind out into the future
in order to see what the Venom symbiot
will become and that's when he Witnesses
Venom's final form he seizes control of
the world and in fact becomes the
entirety of Earth a living planet unto
himself and so when Tyro sees this it's
like he's almost completely overwhelmed
by it he's right how long right how long
do I just stand here watching it I don't
know but when I come back to myself I'm
not the same and that's how Tyro becomes
Meridius right now this is simply just
him taking on that physical form and
even taking on that personality to a
degree but he says it's a vast
Improvement I'm thinking more clearly
than ever and with my new mindset I know
exactly what I have to do to break that
doomed future both the Earth's and mine
and he talks about how Eddie Brock's son
is the key to it because remember one of
the big kickers about Eddie Brock's son
is that he kind of has the powers of the
king in black but on a much smaller
scale he's able to harness control of
Symbiotes but a time will come when he
will kind of inherit the full strength
of his abilities which will be a king in
Black right the ability to just control
all symbiotes Across the Universe kind
of event that people wanted to see was
Eddie Brock fighting his father whether
that would actually happen or not we
still don't know if it will but what
ends up happening is Meridius travel to
King almost immediately after
transforming and because of the fact
that he considers himself a separate
being from Tyro he really just kind of
approaches King that way right he says I
can be a powerful friend King but I can
be a very deadly enemy as well and he's
like how many of your conquests in this
era depend on symbiot technology you can
weed it out of your systems and you will
but here and now all your gains depend
on it as a king in Black I can negate
those gains turn your soldiers against
you or I can turn them off it'd make a
big hole in your plant so if you want
the Symbiotes as your ally because I'm
the one that controls them you need to
work with me right and so what he says
is I want something from you and Kang
asked the question what do you need and
so what ends up happening here is this
explains how the garden was formed in
the first place that the garden itself
is composed of symbiot matter somewhere
along the line every symbiot Across the
Universe was killed it was wiped out and
destroyed really its mind destroyed more
than anything else and its physical form
was gathered together by Meridius and
transformed into the garden removing it
from outside of all space and time
allowing the person who controls the
Garden or who can access its heart to
jump in and out of anywhere along the
time stream in the universe and so this
is how that happened that with the help
of hang they traveled to the very end of
time and discovered that the Symbiotes
had all kind of bonded together waiting
for the collapse of the universe so they
could be reborn in whatever Universe
came next the attack by Kane the
Conqueror is not enough to destroy the
Symbiotes it's enough to severely weaken
them which is all Meridius needs because
what he does is he dives into the heart
of the symbiot world and basically
enters the hive mind and when he does
that he destroys all their minds at one
time
wipes them all out right so literally
it's like somebody just showing up on
Earth and destroying the minds of every
human on earth what our physical body be
there sure but we'd all just kind of be
standing there right empty husks with
vacant expressions and the inability to
think anything because we have no real
Souls no real Consciousness anymore
that's what this is and so with that
being done Meridius in turn used his
control over the symbiot matter to form
the world itself that's how all of this
came into existence it's why it's a
circular pattern because what ends up
happening is with this being done so far
into the future when Eddie Brock dies in
the modern era he wakes up in the garden
so that's kind of how this gets crazy
because Eddie Brock figured that out
Eddie Brock figured out that when he
died he would wake up in the garden go
through these different phases and
eventually become Meridius who in turn
would create the very Garden that Eddie
Brock would wake up in and this was
Meridius way of guarant guing his
existence and then trying to conquer the
entirety of the Universe I know it's
crazy definitely paradoxes and it's very
circular just don't think too hard about
it just accept it for what it is I know
if you're like me it's very difficult to
do right it's very hard to do but still
that's just kind of how it is but notice
this right Meridius is full of huous
he's full of arrogance he's caught up in
himself and so he says the hard work is
already done if any more preparations
are needed I can go back into time and
prepare them nothing can go wrong
because nothing did and as Tyro tries to
talk to him he says my own anger
surprises me I thought I'd feel some
sympathy toward Tyro toward myself but
it's not myself is it it's a sniveling
pathetic wretch a Shabby coat I have far
outgrown it disgusts me and so Meridius
talking to Tyro while Tyro is who
Meridius was before he became Meridius
he doesn't see himself that way right he
doesn't see himself he doesn't see Tyro
as you are what I was before I became me
therefore Grace and empathy are
necessary here instead he just sees him
as a weakened version of himself and so
even then when Tyro starts talking about
the idea that he wants to talk to
Meridius about something this is why at
the beginning of this story Meridius was
dismissive of him here's where things
began to shift and here's where things
changed right this is just the story of
how Meridius became Meridius and under
normal circumstances it would just
preceed this way but when Eddie Brock
right the one who woke up in the garden
he eventually reconstituted his body
after talking to the eventuality so now
he's broken free of this cycle he's
broken free of the cycle where he will
become these different versions of
himself leading up to Meridius now he
can just kind of do whatever he wants
and what he ends up doing is showing up
here in the garden fully powered by the
eventuality itself meaning Eddie Brock
is basically God level right he's
multiversal now showing up to attack
Meridius wipe him out likely destroy the
entirety of the garden and set
everything back to rights but who knows
what form it's going to take so with
that being said guys if you still feel a
little confused make sure you click this
playlist for the Venom videos watching
them will make it so much easier for you
to understand everything that's going on
and I will catch you all later peace